well California detectives believe they
have solved a more than four decades old
cold case thanks to modern DNA
technology James Neal was arrested for
the 1973 murder and sexual assault of 11
year old Linda O'Keefe 48 hours
correspondent Aaron rarity is here with
how a DNA hit on a genealogy website
combined with old-fashioned detective
work led to this arrest Aaron this is
fascinating good morning it is good
morning this investigation has been
going on for so long that the DA in the
case was just one year older than Lind
O'Keefe at the time of her murder he was
just 12 still Newport Beach police say
they've never forgotten the little girl
keeping a photo of her in the Detective
Division as a reminder to continue
pushing forward on cold cases like hers
for more than 45 years the disappearance
of Linda Keefe has haunted the community
of Newport Beach California Wednesday
police revealed how a DNA match on the
genealogy website family tree led them
to their suspect in Colorado 72 year-old
James Neal our investigators used
forensic DNA testing and an online
genealogy website to identify the
suspects DNA as being consistent with
DNA left at the crime scene O'Keefe
vanished in July of 1973 while walking
home from summer school the 11 year old
was last seen on this street talking to
a stranger in a van the next day she was
found strangled her body tossed in a
ditch she was still wearing this dress
her mother had made for her this was the
last picture taken of her O'Keefe sister
Sidney Borghi son says she was surprised
to get the call that the alleged killer
had been caught and I said oh wow okay
you know I never really thought they
would actually ever find the individual
last summer in an effort to jumpstart
the case the Newport Beach Police
Department posted a series of tweets
written as though from O'Keefe's
perspective recalling her final hours hi
I'm Linda O'Keefe I was murdered my
killer was never found my hope is that
it brings hope to other families that
haven't had a resolve yet more police
apartments are turning to genealogical
websites to solve cold cases by
connecting DNA from crime scenes with
online databases authorities have also
been able to track down the suspect at
Golden State Killer as well as the Grim
Sleeper who was convicted in 2016 of
murdering ten people in this case
Newport Beach police also used DNA to
project what O'Keefe's killer might look
like today I can tell you through both
traditional DNA and through genealogical
DNA we have every opportunity in the
world to solve so many of these cold
cases that we never had hope in the past
of solving the Orange County DA would
not say whether it was Neal or a family
member who submitted that DNA to the
genealogy website if convicted Neal
faces life in prison without the
possibility of parole and the DA says
they may consider asking for the death
penalty he's due to appear in a Colorado
courtroom later today it did occur to me
that Lindh O'Keefe would be 57 that
really hit me hard when I parents never
got to see this day to see that someone
had been arrested you know it's very
fascinating how they do these kudos to
the Newport Beach police they never gave
up and then to put it in such an
appealing way to say hi my name is Lindo
keep my body's never been found that
would make somebody pay attention to
what is this about and they did I
honestly think this is now the model for
these whole cases right and think they
got a hit in at one of these databases
and they didn't get it with CODIS right
the federal database variant Aaron thank
you